foreign
[Music]
good evening welcome to the table
come inside come inside
that's a rock and roll song but I'm not
gonna sing it do you all know what song
I'm talking about no I'm not gonna sing
it
all right
y'all good evening I am so thankful to
be here I am so thankful that you are
here
um what a gift what a gift and the only
announcement I have is a very simple one
that right after service there will be a
baptism class with Brett and even if you
didn't sign up for it if you're
interested and want to learn more just
meet him over by the piano right after
service and y'all can talk more about
that
um and as we we gear up and get ready to
enter into a time of worship and getting
to hear the word
um and just being I have a little gift
for you guys I was given this gift this
morning and I thought I would pass it
along because it was just delicious
so and if you don't want this gift you
don't you don't have to do it you don't
have to take it so but if you do I
invite you along to
um close your eyes
take a deep breath in through your nose
and out through your nose
now take your right ear to your right
shoulder
back to Center
left ear to your left shoulder
now with your nose and imaginary line
draw it up the wall to the ceiling
take a deep breath in through your nose
out through your nose
draw that line right back down until
your chin is resting on your neck
back to Center
deep breath in through your nose
out through your nose
and isn't that a delicious gift of just
stretching your neck and being present
in the gift of breath and life and
movement and being here
what a gift and all good gifts come from
God and yoga with Adrian because that's
where I got that one this morning so
um but really my prayer as you enter
into this space and my my thoughts are
just that we can pause and push aside
the plans of busyness for this holiday
season coming up from work from
excitement from hardship from Marriage
woes to Parenthood childhood all the
things that you could just press pause
for a minute and take in the gift of
this worship set the gift of the word
that Brett has prepared and just let it
be a gift for you
and breathe in deeply as you do because
it is these are good things
thanks
Kelly
all right you guys why don't you now
that your neck is all relaxed and
stretched out why don't you stand up
and um
you're always welcome to sit back and
you know relax through the worship set
but one of the things I do like about
just kind of that practice and routine
of standing together to sing is because
um I really feel like the more that
we're able to engage our whole body in
what we do the more holistic worship
becomes and the more it can fill our not
just this section of our week but the
more that we can fill our lives with
this posture of
um of what we do here together and hope
that it bleeds out standing entering in
engaging our senses singing
um I know you guys probably sing in the
shower but for some reason you know we
come here together and you know we're
all self-conscious but but this is a
time for us to actually participate in
the service for us to actually join in
together for it to be a group
um of people worshiping this God of love
this God of transformation nation of
Hope of Peace
so I hope that as we do that together
that we are kind of like taking this
posture not just to stand for a while
but to enter into something together so
I just invite you all into that space
with us
we're going to start with glorious day
and Gary's going to lead us this is Joe
for those of you who are new this is
Ramon on keys and you guys he came
through so clutch for us this week and I
just want to say thank you so much
um it is a gift having him with us this
week I'm really thankful and I'm Mindy
so anyways y'all enter in with us
[Music]
it was
it was too
till I met you
[Music]
I was breathing but not alive
all my failures I tried
too hard
[Music]
it was far too
till I met you
[Music]
you call my name and I ran out of that
grave
out of the darkness and
your glorious day
out of the darkness into the Glorious
Day
now your mercy has saved my soul
[Music]
that I know
Jesus
[Music]
day
Monday
foreign
[Music]
kiddos thank you guys for singing with
us y'all can go to your classes
and we're going to
um
pray the prayers of the people right now
so if you're joining us online please
leave your request in the comments but
if you're here with us for the first
time this is just a old tradition that
goes way way back to the early churches
and it's an opportunity for us to bring
the things that we're carrying that are
heavy on our hearts maybe someone that
you love someone that you know who is
struggling or maybe a situation that's
going on in our nation our world our
city or your workplace that you would
just like to speak out
and give us the opportunity to lift that
up together before God entrust that he's
here with us so would you guys read this
along with me out loud
[Music]
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all of
those who live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to you
Hospital staff
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and Hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
hello
sing I Love You Lord
I love you Lord
for you have delivered me
for you have delivered my soul from my
feet from stumbling I will walk in the
lands
[Music]
foreign
as long as I may live
I love you Lord
for you
[Music]
I love you Lord
for you have delivered my soul from my
feet from stumbling I will walk in the
land of the living my soul from death
[Music]
you are in the land of the living
Scout thank you that you are with us
that you lift our head and you set our
feet on a rock
okay keep doing your work in our hearts
the empty filled the wounded healed the
broken back together
the poorer blessed the weary rest we
will Dance Forever
the blinded see the change in our Dream
the doubtful now believer the outcasts
know the orphan home you are my redeemer
behold
[Music]
home
hope behold What Love Can Do
behold behold
he's
taking all things new
must we turn the voices heard the
morning now rejoicing the mountains
shape the world away
creation of composing the set unto the
Earth
[Music]
the darkness
taking all things new
we've been struck down
we're not destroyed
please
[Music]
we Zone it is
creepy Joy
[Music]
behold
will love can do
behold behold
he's making all things new because
[Music]
we are
he's made things new
he's making all things new
and would we believe you for that would
we trust that we're not going to be
stuck in the same spot today that we
were in yesterday would we trust that
you and your love can change situations
that seem unchangeable
[Music]
you can heal hurts that seem unhealable
you can restore things that seem lost
God would you give us hope
for more than what meets our eyes
more than what makes sense to our minds
would you give us belief in something
bigger than ourselves and what we're
able to control and change and
manipulate would we look to a god of
transformation would we look to a God
who doesn't give up on us
who is constantly at work making things
new restoring forgiving
redeeming
[Music]
in the darkest places of our lives in
the loneliest places would we find you
there
in the most hopeless
would you meet us
would you surprise us
thank you for who you are thank you for
the way that you love us and pull us
forward
and thanks for this time together it's
in your name I pray amen
thank you guys if you want to turn to
the people around you and make them feel
welcomed and at home and then Brett will
come up and get started with our message
and you guys can be seated
all right well good evening grace in
peace my name is Brett and I'm the
pastor here and it's so so good to be
with all of you and as always that
includes of course those joining us
online
we see you see you and um in anyone else
who is new
um among us thank you so much for being
here I know it can take a lot of courage
to walk through that that door and um
enter into a new space
so just know um that you are wanted
you're welcome uh here so thank you so
much for for being with us
um so let's see well I'm probably I'm
going to do a little bit of an audible I
had a whole direction for my sermon I'm
changing things because it's so cold and
Raymond suggested you should preach on
Hellfire and Damnation to warm it up in
here
I thought it was a good joke so I stole
it from him I was like that's genius I'm
gonna open with that so um all right
that's a live course I am uh going to
just proceed with a message I have
planned so we are in a series right now
as as some of you know um titled
stranger things when the Bible gets
weird
and if you ever read the Bible I mean
maybe you haven't and in that case
you're just like huh what do you mean
when the Bible gets weird you've
actually read it or especially you've
like read all the way through you know
some of those obscure stories mostly
from the old there's a few from the new
though
um you know that are just like it yeah
it's a little it's a little out there
and um
so kind of what we've been the really
the premise of the series is that um God
can absolutely speak to us through any
and every scripture
um however
sometimes in order for that to to Really
Happen effectively we end up having to
read the Bible much like the I would say
the early church read it and and really
how the church read the scriptures for
the first 1500 years of its um her
history which was not always to just
take it at the literal level like yep it
said that's what happened and it said
that's what God did and so there you go
um but really the the church wasn't um
well in light of who Christ revealed God
to be they would read the Bible in
creative ways um and they would often
read uh even something that came across
like history and they would say well
well I don't know maybe uh let's read
that as like a parable of sorts for like
this spiritual life or they they would
be really creative with it so um so
that's kind of what we're what we're
gonna do in um especially tonight
because uh if you're if you know if I
don't know if that little intro brings
up more questions than answers in your
mind is like well how does that play out
how does that work
um well then you will uh I think you'll
be glad to know that actually the
scripture tonight
I mean it's the perfect example
it's perfect I'm so I'm really I'm
really excited about this message
um so the the title of it is um
vulnerability and uh the great bear
attack
uh some of you know already and
um
you know
it's yeah it's a fascinating one so how
about just we'll just jump in and we'll
just read the story it's actually quite
short
um Second Kings chapter 2 verses 23
through 24.
and it says this from there Elisha went
up to Bethel as he was walking along the
road some boys
came out of the town and jeered at him
get out of here Baldy
I mean I told you this is stranger
things when the Bible gets weird you're
like yep okay it's official yeah
and then they repeat it for emphasis get
out of here Baldi exclamation mark he
turned around and he looked at them
and he called down a curse on them in
the name of the Lord
then two female Bears came out of the
woods
and mauled
42.
of the boys
and that's it
that's the end of the story
um it's interesting really like in terms
of the overall structure of Second Kings
I don't know it's like it is honestly
it's just a kind of a random little
excursus like a little side road in the
story like also this thing happened and
then just kind of move on
um
so
yeah I think
um
you know
it's it's problematic
um it's problematic and uh there's uh in
my kind of own deconstruction years I
did you know plenty of reading outside
of Christian tradition and so I was
became familiar with um you know folks
who were like outside the church walls
um and I'm thinking of folks who are
often opposed to Faith um someone like
probably the premium example this would
be like Richard Dawkins kind of a famous
you know atheist and um let's be really
clear he Revels in stories like this
he's like this is what I'm talking about
like ha ha what
how Christians how what are you doing I
mean he's just infuriated like this this
is it right
um
and uh it's interesting though because
often Christians get very on their heels
you know in stories like this because
it's kind of apparently because we have
certain assumptions about the Bible like
I said it's not it's really assumptions
from the last few hundred years of
Christianity
um and ways of approaching the Bible
it's not really
um it wasn't as problematic in those
first 1500 years but
um
I'm thinking like for folks like Gregory
of Nissa Macarena the younger even Saint
Augustine would um read scripture quite
creatively I mean I've mentioned this
before but Augustine for example
um read the story of Jesus having the
whip you know and driving out the money
changers out of the temple like this is
my father's house the House of Prayer
you know
of course
it's figurative Jesus would not do
violence and it's like he read that
story as like figurative allegory not as
literal which which I would actually
disagree there with Augustine um because
I don't think Jesus was literally like
ah getting blood from people you know I
mean I think it's more kind of driving
them out whatever
um the point is right those are the
leaders Christians they're creative in
how they'd approach the text
um but
because of certain assumptions we make
about the scriptures now or many
Christians do we get kind of on our
heels you know we feel we start getting
defensive and we feel the need like we
got to defend this
I didn't wear Christian commentators
theologians Scholars will um go is they
will point out a few things and you know
some good points so like they'll point
out for example the terms translated
here as
um boys and some translations are young
boys
is really a combination of two Hebrew
terms um and Katan so naar means what
has a number of meanings you know many
words especially ancient words there's
kind of slippery because their usage
changes over time so it can mean baby uh
it can mean boy young boy youth servant
priest uh so for example in the book of
Exodus when there's little uh cute
little baby Moses in his basket getting
floated down the Nile uh he's described
as naar right a little little baby now
obviously from the context of this story
it's not that not like little babies
um but uh you know but again the usage
can shift so baby boy maybe though it's
also servant or priest so you might
think well maybe adult priests or
something man which should maybe soften
the blow a little bit I mean still 42
people killed by I don't know but you
know maybe
um but then there's that second term
Katan which means like small little
young you know so you kind of have a
certain emphasis here on
age you know so
um you know perhaps we shouldn't be like
in I don't know whatever the image in
your mind's eye there was like you're
envisioning you know kindergarteners I'm
just like oh my gosh this is a horrible
story
um I mean maybe if you're trying to be
charitable maybe it is like I mean
honestly as a former teenage boy myself
uh this sounds like some jerk thing I
would do uh back then you know so maybe
for the sake of argument we could say um
teen boys maybe even young like youthful
teen priests of a rival religious
tradition or something good
um it could be
um
so you know so this is where certain
Christian commentators will go they'll
be like well
um they should have you know these
weren't kindergartners so they should
have known better you know
um other others though uh kind of push
back for example I found this is a guy
he was a pastor and a theologian from
Germany back writing in the 1830s
Friedrich Wilhelm crewmacher he had this
to say he actually wrote a whole book
about Elisha and so he had this to say
about this specific story
um and forgive the kind of outdated
language in a way you can tell he's
writing in 1830s it's kind of funny
though he says a deadly burst of
vengeance upon a troop of 110 years
very 1830s a curse pronounced upon them
in the name of the Lord how
characteristic of the legal dispensation
in other words like the the Old
Testament but how opposite to always
said of the character and call of Elisha
as a messenger of the kindness and love
of God our savior
so you can see where kind of through
Christian history they've grappled with
this story you know in in different ways
and uh overall I'm mostly pretty much
with with
um crewmucker here I think as I alluded
to earlier approached as a just those
story of like Yep this happened and this
is a beautiful revelation of who God is
I think that's a very very problematic
um stance and specifically because of
Jesus that's why I'm not standing here
as like I don't know Protestant liberal
kind of wagging my finger at the Bible
like oh how dare they um it's really I'm
a Christian and so Christ is the perfect
revelation of God so I read scripture
through that through the lens of of
Jesus
um so in in light of this
um
how might we approach this in a little
bit different way what I want to do is
read it as a parable of sorts for kind
of the spiritual life and uh and so
what I'm going to do is I'm actually
drawing from a Christian thinker named
he's from the Eastern Orthodox tradition
but he um is named Jonathan peggio and I
thought he had a good kind of reading in
this story so
um these aren't all my just purely
original thoughts um I'm definitely
drawn from from Peugeot here and found
him very helpful so all right so let's
kind of jump into uh giving this like a
different reading let me start here I
had a a moment that was it was probably
it was a few months ago maybe four or
five months ago and uh it was the day I
realized I was going bald
um something about the very top the
crown of my head it just felt different
it's weird how you like kind of know
your own body you know what I mean and
then it's like you can feel when
something's off
and something was off I was like I just
feel I don't know it was like when I was
in the Wind
it felt different when I was like
shampooing my hair
it was different and so finally I got up
to courage and went out to my backyard
where I have good sunlight no trees and
I got my phone and I was like
you know the the weird selfie and I got
it and then I I looked at it and I was
like oh
oh oh wow
oh wow okay
it's true
I'm going both all right it's and you
know honestly I was proud of myself like
I didn't cry
I like
I was like you know what like honestly
kind of a wave of like peace kind of
washed over me it was like acceptance
you know what I mean like hey I'm
getting older
it comes for us all you know what I mean
like it's okay
it was okay I can deal with this
um now like four days went by and I
started growing back and I realized oh
my gosh Christmas miracle
um my barber had just accidentally cut
too close and it Scout me there
and so actually I wasn't
um
but now I know you're saying see that's
a fake story that's fake vulnerability
you can't relate
um
but you know there is I will say that
for those days like I felt vulnerable
like it was this feeling of like oh okay
this is how bodies are you know now
because it is kind of a fake story let
me share something like a little more
personal okay that actually matters to
me I mean
um that's one of our values here
vulnerable and that wasn't vulnerable
that was fake vulnerable so let's be
real um so I have this in my mid-20s I
realized I had this weird thing some of
you maybe have like just weird things
about like your body and
um
and I have lipomas some of you know
these like they're like lumps thank God
they're like non-cancerous but they're
just like lumps like little little kind
of small to mid-sized lumps and some of
you maybe just have like one or right
but I like a number like kind of a few
of my arms and like my trunk kind of
chest and you know what I mean it's just
like a genetic thing
and I remember when this started
happening in my mid-20s like it was kind
of this
I don't know it was like kind of um
awkward and just sort of like it made me
very aware of like oh wow I'm like
getting older like this is you know I
mean like a thing this I'm not this I
don't know like some perfect whatever
like I have you know this thing and even
to this day like truth be told I like
feel a little bit self-conscious about
them I even think about it sometimes um
like if I'm ever wearing like short
sleeves you know because there's like a
few of them are and I just I don't know
it's just this it's this thing in other
words my point is like to be human
is just to be kind of vulnerable
why it's mostly about our bodies
we are embodied beings
and these bodies are beautiful and
glorious and remarkable
and you know kind of struggling in other
ways you know I mean they get sick and
um right in other words we all we all
have
these things right to be human is to
live with vulnerability
um I I was uh three weeks ago some of
you know my my grandmother passed away
and um she was she was a pretty amazing
woman 94 years old uh when she died and
uh had had stomach cancer for a number
of years
and when we um well you need to know
about her is that she was just um before
she passed like she was so full of life
so vibrant like I heard from my mother
that even just 10 days before her death
she was with her daughters driving
around delivering meals on wheels
lunches to the elderly
yes my 94 year old grandmother with
stomach cancer who 10 days later would
passed away was delivering the meals
like just so vibrant so full of life for
94 years singing I mean she was pretty
incredible person
um and yeah I'll never forget like we
drove through the night to get there and
uh and I walk into her room
and you know there she is like in her
last at that point probably 48 hours and
what struck me was
um just her Frailty and even this woman
who her whole life was so full of life
like so fragile
so vulnerable
and this is what it means
to be human it's to live with a certain
vulnerability and
um
and this is why there's aspects for each
and every one of us there's aspects of
our bodies our faces
our personalities our social skills or
lack of thereof
um even sometimes our stories and our
histories
you know that it's like oh it's just
it's it's our soft spots
you know what I mean are you tracking
with me like it's just our stuff so it's
sort of like um like like like little
like openings in our armor
and it's places where people can kind of
press and when they do
like it hurts like of course we put on a
brave face like oh no big deal but but
no it actually like it is it it like
we're lying Liars you know like it it
hurts when they cut us there
we put on the brave face but it um it
cuts deep
and uh this is why returning kind of to
our Parable well I think again red two
literally this becomes a little bit
silly you know like point out some guy's
bald head and then bears attacking right
it gets a little over the top
um but where I do think if we kind of
take a step back though there is I think
this
um does say something about
vulnerability in other words we might
say it like this there are few things
more awful and foolish than mocking and
exposing the physical or emotional
imperfections and vulnerabilities of
others
uh this is I say awful because
um again the way this can play out like
kind of low level you have like you know
I don't know schoolyard bullying you
know but then the way it scales up
um we're talking like the worst forms of
abuse
right and that's why it's
it's um almost kind of like predatory
reptilian about like saying like knowing
I'm strong in this area and you're weak
so I'm gonna expose that weakness
right it's just like
uh but just the worst of the worst so
that's why it's awful
um but it's foolish for different
reasons this is where I'm drawing on
um Jonathan pajo
um it's foolish though because
it does seem like there's some sort of
uh I don't know what to call it like
kind of weird law of the universe like
some religious tradition is called karma
the Bible calls it like a reaping what
you sow in other words like harvesting
what you plant which can be a good thing
but also a not so good thing but applied
to this story
I think there's kind of a principle that
when I like live a life of chronically
exposing the vulnerability of other
people I create the very conditions for
my own vulnerabilities to be exposed
and uh
I think that's where like this story
like there is something about these I'm
just imagining these like skinny little
teens
with their luscious locks
you know and they're mocking the old
bald prophet and then what happens
suddenly their own vulnerability is just
shockingly on display right it's just
like they go from 42 like yeah to oh my
God you know like it's just the worst
right and I think this is where um like
there's something to this in fact it's
interesting that the uh the story
gives uh in in the Hebrew it literally I
put it in in little
um brackets there but female two female
Bears this specifically says
um says this and uh now I think there's
I wonder if there's something like some
kind of powerful kind of protective like
we could call it feminine Instinct
though by that I don't just mean like
literally biological female you know I
mean but we even have language in our
own culture for this like don't mess
with Mama Bear
right and we kind of we know what that's
talking about
because what's that Mama Bear what's
that instinct it protects the vulnerable
and the weak right and I think that's
that's some of the principle
um and perhaps you say Brett you're
reaching fair enough I'm reaching
um but I do I think there I do think
there's something there's something to
this in fact um a great uh well to come
back to my point this is why another
reason that I do think it's foolish
right to expose because
um we'll sum it up like this when I yeah
when I chronically expose those
vulnerabilities of others I create the
very conditions for my own
vulnerabilities to be exposed and coming
back to our first point
to be human is to be vulnerable
everyone which is why it's just idiotic
to um
to
expose the vulnerabilities of other
people
um something else pajo points out and I
kind of differ from him a little bit in
interpretation but a cultural example
that he gives that you think is a good
one um is the metoo movement
I think that's a perfect modern example
of this principle play now I mean what
was me too about right you had people
mostly men
um who did what used their position
their power could be physical
um it was social they're placed in the
hierarchy
and then what do they do they prayed
upon the vulnerabilities of others
primarily women they're not exclusively
right but others with less power
and they knew that they were weaker they
knew that they were vulnerable
and they prayed upon that
and then what happened
they created the very conditions
for their own vulnerabilities to go
shockingly on display even people that
thought they were utterly invulnerable
like no way anyone ever gets me have too
much money you know and yet even them
I'll go ahead and curse for emphasis
their ass is now in jail
right and there's something
um there's Justice there
right
um
I think that's this this story
um playing out when I expose the
vulnerabilities of others I make myself
vulnerable now that's all pretty intense
and um kind of depressing honestly um so
here's maybe let's let's uh shift to
some good news
if it's true that there is nothing kind
of more awful than like exposing the
vulnerabilities of others and preying
upon that and like some reptilian way
then might also be true that there are a
few things more beautiful than honoring
and protecting the vulnerability of the
people around you
and in the same way there's kind of a
curse like hiding in The Chronic
exposure of people's vulner
vulnerability might there also be a
blessing in the opposite when I honor
and protect the vulnerabilities of
others what happens I'm creating the
very conditions for my own
vulnerabilities to be honored and
protected
so let's get um really practical here
like what might this kind of look like
or mean for a community like ours first
thing I think it means physical
emotional or sexual abuse is not
acceptable behavior that's putting it
mildly it's just not there's no room for
that in the kingdom of God I mean not
least of which because we serve Jesus
Christ
the one who himself hung naked on a
cross the one who's very bodily
vulnerabilities was so exposed and
shamed and then we we
um Worship in love and adore Christ
right that like sets the tone for what
kind of culture the church at least is
called to be obviously we at times
really struggle to live into that but
still that is the ideal
um and so that means whether it's like a
one spouse or partner taking advantage
of their Partners physical or emotional
or mental vulnerability whether it's a
parent taking advantage of the child or
in the later years maybe vice versa
a child taking advantage of their own
parents maybe physical or mental
um incapacity or vulnerability
um there's or even thinking back to our
Balaam sermon two weeks ago that kicked
off our Series right even in a setting
like this you could have like there's
such a thing as like spiritual abuse
right whether it's Pastor or leader
someone with influence kind of using
that power
to manipulate others like uh
no
no that
that's the way of Bala and that's the
way of
really Antichrist right
um so that's that's the first takeaway I
think second is be very careful what you
share about another person
um when they're not present this would
be like a gentler version you know
because I don't think it's always so
like extreme like abused you know it
could it could be more mild versions
like I'm thinking even the way um many
of you are involved in meetups and those
are when they're working they're
supposed to be places where people can
share
honestly vulnerably about their lives
um but because they've done that right
now you've been kind of entrusted
with parts of their story right they've
in essence made themselves vulnerable
so then there has to you have to really
guard and protect that
one good principle is if you're not sure
like wait was that like private
information or not if you're not sure
don't say it that's usually the best
like just air on the side of caution if
you're not sure just don't don't say it
um third
efforts at societal Justice are not only
beautiful acts on behalf of victims they
are acts of generosity for society as a
whole they keep those bloody bears at
Bay I'm thinking of the way this plays
out like a leadership level it's easy
for leaders
um of any like anything to get I don't
know a little bit annoyed at the
Enneagram Eights in their you know in
their organization or life and I'm
thinking anyway so you know like justice
people you know I mean I want the truth
um and they're about accountability you
know what I mean and there's it's easy
um
it's easy for that to be like an
antagonistic relationship when actually
I think that's a very foolish for
leaders to act like that to kind of shun
accountability to shine like oh stop
stop that's annoying like no because
actually
um they are our best friends
like I would rather have the gentle
loving wounds of a friend today who's
like kind of keeping me accountable
then face the mauling Bears of Justice
five years from now can I get an amen
like that's it's a last thing in a gift
whether we're talking at the political
Level Church level you know corporate
worlds like don't shun the
accountability don't no no no no no no
no no invite it invite it invite it's
it's good it's gonna be challenging and
hard but it's it's a blessing and a gift
so there is something There's Something
Beautiful In Christ like about
protecting and honoring the
vulnerabilities of others and I'll close
with this story I'm thinking of Jesus
and in John chapter seven there's that
beautiful story
um of the the woman who these religious
leaders drag this woman forward and say
that we caught her in the very active
adultery how on Earth they did that it
just sounds like a strange story and
it's like hmm okay but allegedly that's
what they happen and it drag her forward
and of course Jesus was preaching to a
large crowd so you've got kind of the um
and they pick up Stones by the way the
religious leaders pick up stones to
um like Stone her and so it's this
moment just fraught with like violence
and danger and I mean this in This
Woman's very very vulnerable and for
those who remember the story you know
that instead of either kind of cow
Towing to them and like oh well yeah
there are scriptures that say that's
what should happen you know
um or instead of trying to fight them
off and like yelling at them or
something and so instead Jesus just very
calmly asked them a question
how about
he among you who's without sin go ahead
and throw the first stone
and one by one
they drop their rocks and walk away
I think that's one of the most beautiful
Jesus stories and it's the perfect
example of what we're talking about
tonight this is our call
to honor to protect to create a culture
that honors that protects that covers
the vulnerability of other people rather
than exposing it so as we come to the
table of the Lord tonight as we take in
the body of Christ in the bread the
blood of Christ in the wine it's a it's
a moment
to both commune and connect with the
Christ who made himself vulnerable
but it's also a moment to connect to
commune
um
with or really two you might say kind of
to receive
covering to receive love to be met by
the Jesus who knows all of our pain
all of our shame
all the crappy things that have happened
in our life and yet
covers loves
protects
honors
and so I hope that as we take communion
tonight there can be like an ad
um Beauty and meaning in it that can
relate to your own vulnerability
so we practice what's called an open
table
here at the table meaning basically if
you're here tonight and you would like
to participate then you are welcome to
do that no theological police checking
your credentials or something you're
just welcome to participate
we the way we're going to do it is kind
of go just kind of row by row that way
we don't get like too long of a line
that you know backs up and all that so
you just kind of we'll start at the
front and then you can just layer upon
layer go ahead and come forward as you
would like of course having said that
there's no like pressure that everyone
must come forward if you don't want to
that's perfectly fine too also in terms
of taking it you're welcome to just take
the elements whenever you'd like whether
immediately if you want to return to
your seat have a moment of prayer then
partake that's great too
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith and
you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here come to the table
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I love the words of this song because I
feel like so many of us come into church
spaces especially and a lot of us come
in here with wounds from past Church
experiences or spiritual experiences
where maybe some of our vulnerabilities
were exploited not cared for not honored
and that's definitely not the kind of
community that we want to be instead we
want to make room in space for people to
be themselves and not be afraid
for them to be fully who God made them
to be in all of our quirks and
eccentricities and even our flaws even
our failures and that not be something
that makes us less valuable but
something that unites us something where
we're able to make space for each other
room for each other
so I just invite you to sit back and
listen to these words and let's create
this kind of culture this kind of
community together
like this
you're in a place you think you know
surrounded but you feel alone
you have a place to rest your head but
not a whole
feels like you've lost yourself again
sit in the Silence of a friend when you
are fully know
don't you have a home
the burden you choose to wear
keeping yourself from those who care
problems and cry play hide and seek your
unaware
that all of the things you keep
concealed one day are bound to be
revealed we hate the picture of
ourselves that it isn't real
feels like you've lost yourself again
[Music]
you have a heart
you have a home
[Music]
foreign
you have a heart
in time
may you find
[Music]
peace of mind
with me my friend
[Music]
that that was good that got me thank
y'all thank y'all
um so much they got me because it hit
very close to home
um just this last week I was really
struggling with some things that I
chronically struggle with
um that flare up every now and then and
I didn't tell my close friend group
until after I was up from underwater and
I was like guys I'm back here I am
really underwater and while I was
underwater I I did
um feel so alone and I was like why
aren't my friends reaching out because
they don't know we don't know you don't
you don't know how to help someone if
you don't know they're drowning and what
a blessing it is to have friends in this
um in this place in this community and
get to call this home who do care if
you're underwater
but if they don't know they can't reach
you there and that my sister-in-law
pulled me aside and she said you you
robbed me of getting to help you when
you don't tell me you're struggling
um and I yeah vulnerability begets
vulnerability and in her sharing that
she was vulnerable and just saying like
hey it that hurt that you didn't share
that and so I
that is the the like-mindedness of this
group of people that you are welcome to
join in in their meetup groups who have
people who are of that caliber of caring
of wanting to sit in the Silence with
you of wanting to show up to be your
ally to be your cheerleader and that is
the truth so I super encourage you
um to find a Meetup Group you can hop
online if this is your first time
visiting and you would like more
information on how to get plugged in and
have the friends that want to dive in
deep with you as you walk out to your
right is a little box where you can fill
out an information card and someone will
reach out to you this week and good to
hear your story and how we can plug you
in and love you well and stand alongside
you or drown with you
um that's good stuff and
right after service again Brett will be
meeting anyone who's interested in our
baptism class right up here by the piano
you didn't have to sign up for that if
you did good job you you get a gold
start and if you didn't sign up just
show up
um
and I'm going to close this out with a
benediction which is just a blessing for
the road
and I invite you to again go back to the
place of deep breath of centering and to
receive this as you go into your week
So Close Your Eyes
breath in through the nose
and out
may you receive these words to your
heart of hearts
you are a child of God
you are a child of God this is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day so as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's holy spirit in
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
deep breath in
deep breath out
let's be with you
[Music]
next week